I lost my family three years ago they  would kill I have nothing left  I'm finding people who did this I'll  kill every last one of them I need your  help  stop don't panic B can't be still shoot  me what right here we gotta get you  rhythm section under control and give  your heart as the drums your breathing  is the bass that's the easy part  what's the hard part living with it  we're gonna have to be someone else  let's go  [Music]  I'm gonna do this my way a lot of people  think that you're dead I get that a lot  they give you a heart is the trumps your  breathing is the face the rhythm section  what are you gonna do to minify it we  take too long how long the menopause  will be a distant memory it's a good  stuff  you